welcome to this video playing me cool
from France okay let's play one of my
regular openings for change the double
fianchetto against the Kings Indian a
solid opening for white and quite often
an opening that black players have have
some issues dealing with see it again
and again tonight on a five hmm Stairway
to exploit that looks bit strange to go
to a five here that early I don't see it
though I always has got c5 so let's just
play normal now I can I can actually
take which is not too bad now come on
let's take it takes with the night it
took him some time to play Knight a5 and
so on and checking with the porn i would
have at c5 at least this would have been
an idea okay yeah yeah well be five is
not playable here I guess because of 95
95 is an interesting move anyway but if
he takes Bishop g7 there's always night
III this is quite a funny move with you
need to take into account so cannot
really play that 95 okay
Queen d2 yeah maybe Queen d2
ki is playing very cool claim 95 that's
nighty for Quincy to Bishop b2 queen bee
tool yeah it still feels like a good
position taking one c4i tag when f6 this
is really bad taking on d5 CD 5s is
downright awful because of the c6
weakness he basically has to play that
before I think 94 seems almost fast
Quincy to then we should be to queen bee
to takes on c4 whoopsie form yeah this
looks like a convenient position for
white nothing spectacular but nice he's
taking some time don't yeah maybe
theoretically speaking he could think
about a move they are moving the night
98 or something but this is also did we
had
here catus I consider to be unplayable
now you have a completely destroyed
structure d 6 a-6 f6 white is to pawn
islands black ass 3 this is the kind of
position that an excellent technical
player winsor basically in a sleep which
not saying that i will do that but give
that to 22 mungus cards and aunty will
win every game against anybody okay but
this is very nice now Knight e5 rock
default basically gives up the d6 bond
how is it going to to cover that now I
don't see how
yeah it was a very strange decision to
take on see form if maybe he's just
somehow didn't see 94 I mean possible if
you don't see this move on you're
basically in big trouble everything else
is just really bad okay I can play a
boxy one first and then take on d6 don't
have a good square for the Queen anyway
maybe to a seven not but it's not
particularly great okay should I take on
e5 first and takes with the pawn rook
takes yeah i can i can take with you
yeah let's consider I could I could
simply take here yeah and i will add so
it's simple and good attacking a six now
and d5 what i need to be aware of is
that I have a slight background issue
but not now I could just take it black
resigns yeah I really fell apart him I
guess somehow he didn't up to this point
everything was was quite quite normal
but he somehow didn't didn't seek 94 I
think and if you don't see the move for
some reason then you're in big trouble
you don't have any other movie to do
that Quincy to and this was the line
that I that I gave during the game and
here why does typically slightly better
because b 5 has weakened the C file
let's say for instance after that it's
slightly tricky the night here for
example if it goes to c5 you also need
to reckon with this this is a maneuver
note that the night and the rook are
both attacking pieces so I'm not so
great and after that chassis is
basically gone I mean how do you defend
all your weaknesses here it's it's
already material awesome but I cannot
avoid and at the end you still have
weaknesses sometimes if you lose a pawn
but you you lose the only weakness then
it's not so terrible but here you lose a
pond and just sit on further weaknesses
so it's simply impossible to hold
alright thanks for watching